jusqu'à tout récemment il fallait être
inventifs pour faire aimer un vin
québécois
l'auteur du célèbre guide phaneuf en
sait quelque chose elle piège ses amis
en leur faisant déguster un aveugle je
les fais avec mes amis le plus noble et
le plus fort c'est que les commentaires
étaient pas du tout j'ai c'est bon le
québec sait faire des bons vins et pour
leur donner une visibilité
ils ont maintenant une indication
géographique protégée
liger pc ce un territoire géographique
accès les laurentides qui s'en va
jusqu'aux frontières américaines s'en
vont après seule frontière avec
l'ontario la pression des appalaches
il ya un peu plus d'une centaine de
producteurs de vin au québec la plupart
vont débourser les 1000 dollars par an
pour obtenir sept gp et devront
satisfaire sans critères dont un test
gustatif un gage de transparence quincé
bon des fois les gens ont des doutes sur
che sont un peu déstabilisés
on avait coûté la vie à québec ont
déstabilisé mais là maintenant falloir
prouver que oui c'est québécois il ya
une traçabilité cvc verger près concert
c'est vraiment du 100% québec pour le
propriétaire du vignoble saint jacques
en montérégie
c'est un aboutissement mais aussi le
début d'autre chose
en fait le vignoble québécois est aussi
lent des stands moi c'est l'appellation
ngp et tout silence sinon plus longue
que le vignoble français de nos
ressources à vous donner une des est-ce
qu'on oserait dire que la champagne
c'est comme le languedoc-roussillon jeu
mais pourquoi le faire pour le québec
la prochaine étape c'est donc de
délimiter chaque terroir avec ses
caractéristiques blanche donne une
grande fondation comme la maison et on
voit sur les pièces et les pièces
jointes lui sous région qui vont se
dessiner donc je présume que mes
collègues de l'est lorient vont demander
rapidement sous région il dort les
impôts c'est facile à délimiter
et ce n'est pas son ami vigneron qui
dira le contraire certains raisin
québécois peuvent réserver des surprises
l'un d'entre eux s'appelle le vandale
klich du vandale klich qui qui pousse
bien la région de québec qui pousse bien
chez nous mais chez nous qui fait des
vins de glace dans le vert de l'experte
ici c'est un pinot noir du domaine du
nival au bord de la rivière yamaska
s'est plaint ces croquants ses juteux
mais en même temps qu'ils appellent un
second revers s'est pas demandé minutes
vraiment et quand j'ai goûté ce vin je
me suis dit je pense qu'on arrive à
l'étape mais la production québécoise
reste une goutte d'eau deux millions et
demi de bouteilles sur les 240 millions
écoulés l'année dernière au québec yvan
quirion est persuadé que ce sera à
quatre fois plus dans dix ans à peine je
nous imagine dans un chaland à des
génois palin à quelques années où je
combatte la bosse chaland en a 20 des
vins français des vins italiens des vins
d'allemagne des vins de la californie
juste par notre folie et aussi un peu de
savoir-faire qui explique qu'aujourd'hui
les vignerons du québec ne fournissent
pas suffisamment face à la demande
si mathieu prost radio canada